la place de la révolution la bien nommée
comme une cour des miracles
un concentré et d'horreur de corps
brisés de gueules cassées
la chorégraphie est minimaliste qui mêle
stupeur et tremblements
la deuxième phrase du serment
d'hippocrate dit mon premier souci en
tant que médecin sera de rétablir de
préserver ou de promouvoir la santé dans
tous ses éléments physiques et mentaux
individuels et sociaux nous sommes
légitimes entre paroles de ce débat
porte étendard du rejet d arme sublétale
le professeur thiney c'est l'un des
rares à prendre la parole dans le
silence étourdissant de ses confrères
d'autres ne mâchent pas leurs mots qui
parlent d'expériences hélas balle au
point on dit sur dix ans et une arme non
létale
je suis désolé je suis moi comme
monsieur est un ancien militaire ça fait
plus de dégâts qu'une balle cicatrices
nerfs à fleur de chair à la hoffman
patriotes médaille le revers est tombé
dans le brouillard des lacrymo lors de
l'acte iii celui qui aurait pu être le
dernier pour lui dans mon coeur moi je
représente tous les messages intéresser
tous les morts les éborgné ce qu'ont eu
les mains arrachées
moi j'ai eu de chance ce jour là c'est
d'avoir été touchés par visage et ne pas
avoir eu la carotide ouverte et je
continuerai vraiment vraiment jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à la fin on combat un combat
qui s'annonce rude
le sénat vient en effet de refuser la
suspension d arme sublétale et ce en
dépit des interventions du défenseur des
droits du conseil de l'europe et
dernièrement de l'onu il faut qu'il
entende raison parce qu'on peut pas
continuer comme ça à ternir l'image de
la france qui est maintenant mis au ban
des nations
parmi des pays comme
le venezuela on le suit donc on critique
d'être des dictatures et maintenant
c'est la haut commissaire aux droits de
l'homme de l'onu qui se prononce contre
notre notre pays c'est quand même très
inquiétant et nous en tant que ça nous
on est là aussi c'est notre devoir de
informer sur la dangerosité de ces zones
depuis le 17 novembre treize mille
balles lbd ont été tirés
217 personnes blessées 162 enquête pour
suspicion de violences policières ouvert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]